hey everybody it's Mike for you here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control
sc.l2-3.13.4 prevent unauthorized and
unintended information transfer via
system uh resources excuse me via shared
system resources
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all of this
cmmc dfars and nist SP harder 101
compliance stuff on top of an already
colossal workload well I've got great
news for you you found your home here at
on-call compliance Solutions where we
can help you transform into your
company's on-call compliance Hero Let's
jump into it so uh all right on this one
there are a few uh really a lot of ways
information transfer can occur which is
not intended a great example is access
to cui on shared drives which are mapped
to computers or accounts they should not
be there are lots of other ways to go uh
but but to go directly to what the
assessors are after here let's head
straight to what the assessors really
want to see all right they're really
looking for one thing determine if
unauthorized and unintended information
transfer via shared system resources is
prevented uh we would probably give a
couple of examples we would say hey it's
prevented via file system permissions
and Patch management to prevent exploits
allowing unintended information
transferred by attackers and again we
would honestly just probably show them
different elements of our system that
are you know things like permissions and
access lists to demonstrate compliance
with this control
if you're scratching your head you're
going Mike that made no sense to me or
I've been banging my head against the
wall for this on this control for a
while and you're just trying to figure
all this stuff out I totally get it
that's exactly why we make this video
series because it on call we work with
defense contractors just like you who've
had this dfar's nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped in their laps
like a single on a sunny day and we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps gray areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance has your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmmc complianceecrets.com
or check out the bio below for links to
get help right now if you love the
content we're putting out there for you
help us out with a big thumbs up on that
like button or even better smash the
Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance starts roll it out until the
next compliance tip my friends stay safe
and secure out there and hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance I'll
see you on the next one
foreign
[Music]